- [Peter] Apparently, I'm grown up,
but I still go to places
that I've always dreamt of as a child.
I grew up on a farm,
so there were really no
other kids to play with.
So I ended up just going
into my imagination.
My world is full of
futuristic superheroes,
laser beams, spaceships, and constructions.
I thought I'd be an inventor
so I became an engineer
but the imagination
isn't really encouraged
when you're an engineer.
Luckily, I found my own path.
I try to maintain that
sense of magic and wonder
that we often lose as adults.
(electronic music)
I can actually be myself in this costume.
I'm kind of expected to
be unique and unusual,
which suits me fine.
(upbeat music)
I found this place to
go to on a Monday night.
Everyone goes crazy in the dark.
I could actually shed some light
on something you don't normally see,
splitting audio.
- [Male] Welcome to No
Lights, No Light Crowd.
(upbeat music)
- [Peter] So when the lights go out,
no one's watching you.
You know, you can get away
with whatever you want.
(upbeat music)
It feels like you are in some music video.
It feels like everyone around
you is an amazing dancer,
super sexy, fantastically cool.
(applause)
When the lights come back on,
some sort of transformation has happened.
I don't know what they've
been doing there in the dark,
you hear it and you're a part of it
but I love the way you can't
see the transformation.
The feeling I get when
I'm dancing in the dark,
when you're free and
connected with your body
and with the community,
has basically been the
driving force behind my art.